as a boys head home they still face
potential physical and psychological
challenges dr. Jon LaPook is here to
discuss that part of the story we look
at them that we've told that they've
gained at least seven pounds each they
look so healthy how do they look to you
they actually looked fine they had lost
about nine so they gained almost all of
it back and on their faces they look
good the 11 year old looked like a kid
you know kind of smiling I do the tale
of rescue was remarkable too just to
hear some of the details that they'd
like getting there in the dark and the
coach is trying to figure out whether
there's a way out so there's a rope so
he said if I shake it twice then you'll
know I can get out but he wasn't able to
get out or that I can't get out they
were signaling each other that way they
were looking for the water and it turns
out there was water coming off the side
of the cave and they found they could
drink this there was no food they had to
make a decision do you go forward do you
go backwards they thought maybe if we go
backwards there will be some sort of
exit to the cave there that turned out
not to be true but now that they're out
as a doctor what concerns do you have I
am worried about what could happen when
the camera lights go off so right now
they're in there in emergency mode still
the Adrenaline's flowing the cortisol is
flowing but weeks or months or even
longer than that later when they're
quiet when the press isn't around when
they're not getting all this attention
they are an increased risk for anxiety
depression of course PTSD it's more of a
risk in somebody who goes in with a
psychological problem if you have a
anxious or depressed to begin with but
there are things that can trigger this
later of course think of all the things
being in the dark being cold it was very
scary for them when it got dark out and
there's no ability to see now knowing
that they could swim I mean we were
really concerned that they wouldn't even
be able to swim as they started their
descent so that that that is good news
of that to clear that up for us but from
a psychological standpoint does their
age benefit them that they are so young
of course we're thinking back to the
Chilean miners who were you know much
older and a lot of them did go through
psychological problems yeah I think
being being young is often good because
you're more resilient you're physically
stronger but it certainly doesn't
immunize you from any kind of problem
and I think you know one of the things
that I speaking to
clinical psychologists about this that
when they get home they may be a little
more clingy they may be afraid of the
dark
and they may have anxiety about you know
could this happen again something could
remind them of it's their swimming and
they feel the water anything could
trigger it but they sure look pretty
good don't they yeah yeah don't
necessarily have the structure to make
sure they're mentally okay for a long
period of time the way kids you know in
New York City - yeah and I loved the
fact that they had a psychiatrist a
psychologist they said there's a support
system I do worry about the whole issue
this this saman Coonan is the Thai Navy
SEAL who died trying to do the rescue
and they mentioned just now that they
felt guilty about that and I I do worry
about when it gets kamar when the lights
are off that they might start feeling
some guilt about that so I think this is
you know it's very exciting right now
it's fantastic and what a story for the
world at a time when there's a lot of
friction nobody seems to be able to
agree about anything but the entire
world got together for one moment and
agreed let's get these kids out rooting
for them that's a good part of the story
thank you John